1 2 3 4 5
這樣也是一樣 敲36下
你常常敲
可以防止掉髮還能睡得好
記憶力也變好哦
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
坐在我旁邊這一位美女
她是我的髮型設計師
衣婕
她有40多年的美髮經驗
40多年
年齡都暴露出來了
來掌聲歡迎衣婕
嗨 大家好 我是衣婕
我是胡醫師的髮型師
也是他的鐵粉哦
為什麼會請衣婕來上我的節目呢
中醫看病我們會先分清楚
內因 外因
掉髮的內因
大概就是肝腎失衡
氣血供應不足
而外因呢
往往就是來自每天重複的動作
洗頭 護髮等等的方式不當了
衣婕 你怎麼看掉髮這件事啊
我發現啊
有很多的客人
他們並不是
天生的容易掉頭髮哦
而是洗頭 吹頭髮的方式錯誤
導致掉髮的問題
越來越嚴重
這是真的哦 所以
我們今天請衣婕來教大家
正確的洗頭跟護髮的方法
狂掉髮、髮際線後退？
1按摩法 增髮防掉髮
胡醫師
我有一位50歲的客人
他知道我要來上你的節目哦
拜託我來問你一個問題
他最近睡不好
整天累累的
記憶力也衰退
而且啊
還有明顯的掉髮問題
他想要問你
怎麼樣睡得好 記憶力變好
而且怎麼樣防止掉髮的問題
來 你的這些問題
用一個方法
統統都可以改善
這個方法就是
敲頭按摩法
先把手這樣握起來
大拇指收進手掌裡
像這樣子
我們先敲一敲
我們先敲一敲頭頂
1 2 3 4 5 這樣子敲
動作大概敲36下
再敲
側頭
1 2 3 4 5
這樣也是一樣 敲36下
再敲
額頭前方
1 2 3 4 5
也敲它36下
敲一敲
後腦勺
1 2 3 4 5
也是一樣 敲36下
記住
就這5個地方 做36下
敲完以後你會覺得
頭皮有一點點脹脹的
代表血液循環活絡起來了
真的耶
我剛剛在敲的時候
好像被電電到一樣
頭皮熱熱麻麻的
哇 真棒真棒
中醫他說
髮為血之餘
頭髮要靠氣血來滋養
像這樣子敲一敲頭啊
一次就刺激到
督脈 膀胱經還有膽經
這三條經絡
把氣血帶到頭皮
活化毛囊
讓頭髮的根有力
防止繼續的掉頭髮
古書上講 頭是諸陽之會
敲一敲頭部 改善
改善頭昏 記憶力減退
還有晚上也可以
睡得香香的
你剛剛幫我梳頭的時候
小編和我美麗的太太
都說蠻帥的 真英俊哦
我剛剛在幫你梳頭的時候
幫你的頭髮梳到有蓬度的時候
當然看起來蠻帥的
好 那現在就請你分享一下
怎麼樣梳頭才能夠使它
變得比較有立體感
比較豐盈一點呢
如果你的頭髮
是少、軟、細的人
像我這種的
睡一覺醒來照鏡子的時候
你發現頭髮塌塌的
這個梳頭方法
你一定要試試看哦
你先用梳子
從後腦勺往前梳
不是順著梳哦
把打結的地方梳開
洗頭的時候
頭髮才不會打結
才不會拉扯到你的頭皮
你從後往前梳頭髮的時候
每天都這樣梳頭
頭皮就會有彈性
頭髮就會變得蓬鬆哦
這兩種方法很簡單又實用
你學會了嗎
產後更年期掉髮怎麼辦
頭髮稀疏吃5種食物
很多女生都有這種感覺
年輕的時候熬夜 亂吃
頭髮還都能夠撐得住
40歲一過
怎麼保養怎麼按摩
頭髮都是一直掉一直掉
為什麼會這樣呢
最常見的3個原因
肝腎不足 氣血虛弱
還有肝鬱氣滯
我來先講第一個
肝腎不足
女生產後或更年期前後
她的那個雌激素就開始下降
中醫就講 肝血就不足
毛囊營養就不夠了
結果頭髮就變細 變乾
容易掉了
那像這樣的人
頭髮一直掉
要吃什麼
頭髮才能長回來呀
好 吃5種食物
黑芝麻 核桃 黑豆 枸杞 山藥
這些食物都能夠幫助你
補肝補腎
讓頭髮變得
烏黑濃密
第二個是
氣血虛弱導致落髮
髮為血之餘
你的氣血不夠
頭皮的供血不夠啦
那毛囊就像手機沒了電
你怎麼按
都開不了機不是嗎
氣血虛弱引發的掉頭髮
喝什麼湯
四物湯
我有看胡醫師的節目
四物湯男人也可以喝耶
不錯哦 你還真有概念哦
常常容易感覺到
疲累 臉色蒼白的人
來喝1碗四物雞湯
幫你補血養頭髮很讚哦
第三個
肝鬱氣滯
壓力大 情緒不好
氣血運行不順
讓你一覺醒來
枕頭上都是頭髮
真的捏 我看過一些客人
壓力大的時候
他的頭皮 脖子都很緊繃
掉髮量還特別多
壓力很大的人
你可以常常吃
金針
像是金針排骨湯
金針被稱作為
忘憂草
你知道嗎
能安定神經 平復情緒
而且氣順了的話
掉頭髮自然就減少了
不是老化
3種NG習慣害你狂掉髮
中醫看病 有內因和外因
掉髮除了跟臟腑有關係
你的洗髮習慣不好
就你的觀察哦
有哪些習慣是不好的
就會造成掉頭髮呢
第1個是常常染頭髮 燙頭髮
第2個是頭髮沒有洗乾淨
第3個 頭髮沒吹乾就跑去睡
我先來說第一個
你是經常染頭髮
燙頭髮的人要注意哦
這些產品含有各種化學成份
會刺激你的頭皮
讓毛囊更脆弱
頭髮變得更細
我幫我的粉絲問一下
染頭髮跟燙頭髮
哪一個傷害比較大
傷害最大的就是
你的錢包
認真說起來
染髮比燙髮更傷
很多媽媽 阿嬤愛美
只要白頭髮長出來一點點
就想把白髮染黑
這一種是最傷頭皮的
我建議你染頭髮跟染頭髮之間
燙頭髮跟燙頭髮之間
間隔至少要3個月
讓你的頭皮有時間修護
才不會讓頭髮快速受損
第二個
沒有把頭髮洗乾淨
跟你分享
該怎麼樣把頭洗乾淨
才不會掉很多頭髮
最重要的我要講3遍
洗頭髮一定要洗2次
洗2次
有聽懂嗎
第1次是把頭髮上的髒汙洗掉
洗第2次是把你的頭皮洗乾淨
你在洗頭前把頭髮梳開
再用溫水將頭髮沖濕
在手上擠出適量的洗髮精
有些人直接就把
洗髮精在頭皮上搓洗
千萬不要這樣做
這樣會洗不乾淨
長期這樣做會造成
掉髮
你在髮尾上先搓出泡泡以後
再到頭皮上按摩3-5分鐘
用溫水沖洗
你會發現這樣洗
頭髮上的洗髮精
很容易沖乾淨
因為有做乳化的動作
洗髮精不會殘留在頭髮上
就不容易掉髮
第三個傷害頭髮的習慣就是
頭髮沒吹乾就去睡
有很多人因為工作一整天
回到家很疲累
洗完頭就把頭髮趕快吹一吹
甚至有人連吹都懶得吹
剛剛小編還問我
頭髮一定要吹全乾嗎
當然一定要
這很重要
這是我常常提醒客人的一句話
頭髮沒吹乾
毛囊長時間處在
潮濕的狀態下
容易滋生細菌和黴菌
那引發毛囊炎
久了毛囊功能就變差
你的頭髮就會越掉越多
怎麼選對適合的洗髮精
1秘訣選對洗髮精
有些人擔心天天洗頭
會更容易掉頭髮嗎
到底是天天洗
還是兩天洗一次
還是根本不洗呢
客人也常常問我
我會跟客人說
可以天天洗
如果你天天洗很容易癢
通常不是天天洗這個問題
而是沒有選對洗髮精
那怎麼挑選
自己適合的洗髮精呢
先觀察你的頭皮
多久會出油
如果你洗完頭髮
到了隔天中午瀏海就出油
髮根扁塌
這就是油性頭皮
如果是1天到1天半才出油
這是中性頭皮
如果你是兩天都不出油的
這就是乾性頭皮
要這樣觀察
就能選對適合你的洗髮精
今天我和衣婕跟你分享的
養頭髮防掉髮的方法
你學會了嗎
你自己還有
養頭髮的秘訣嗎
請分享給我哦
這是你的頭髮嗎
怎麼會掉那麼多
ㄟ 我的假髮勒
你幹嘛拿我的假髮
這是我的假髮啊
原來是你的假髮
親愛的粉絲們
我們已經開啟會員頻道了
如果你認同我推廣中醫
照顧自己健康的理念
歡迎每月小額支持
只要花兩杯咖啡的錢喔
或成為VIP贊助者
有你同行
我們才能走得更遠
真心感謝你哦